Trascrizione: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Ludovica Harley
Buonasera.
Ebbene sì, la storia
che vi racconto
non è una storia tanto
a buon fine
perché è un po' la storia
della nostra vita,
è la storia di come il tempo passa.
Sono sicuro che molti di voi
si saranno chiesti:
"Quanto tempo vivrò io?"
Se voi guardate le statistiche
sono veramente impressionanti:
una persona che nasceva nell'antica Roma
aveva un'aspettativa di vita di 22 anni.
Questo vuol dire che
più del 50% delle persone
non ce la facevano
oltre questo periodo di tempo,
ovviamente è una statistica
molto inficiata
dalla alta mortalità
subito dopo la nascita,
ma, se guardiamo anche il '900,
meno di 50 anni, 49 anni.
E poi un grande salto
all'inizio del 2000: 26 anni.
Abbiamo guadagnato
più di 25 anni soltanto in un secolo.
Queste sono le ultime statistiche
dell'Organizzazione Mondiale della Sanità,
i primi dieci posti della statistica,
noi in Italia siamo al sesto posto adesso:
84.8 di sopravvivenza per le femmine
e 80.5 per l'uomo, quindi
più di 80 anni per entrambi i sessi,
stiamo andando molto bene,
abbiamo guadagnato ancora moltissimo
rispetto a soltanto a
una decina di anni fa.
Se voi immaginaste un mondo perfetto
in cui la medicina cura tutte le malattie;
in cui le malattie infettive
sono prevenute dai vaccini;
in cui il cancro non esiste;
in cui gli incidenti vengono riparati;
in cui tutto funziona in maniera perfetta,
saremmo immortali?
Purtroppo la risposta è no.
Noi abbiamo da qualche parte scritto
nella nostra informazione genetica,
un'informazione che fa sì che
tutti i membri della specie homo sapiens,
quindi noi, viviamo
un massimo di 120, 125 anni.
Ed è un'informazione
genetica strettissima,
come è strettissima per tutto
quello che vive sul pianeta terra:
un topo vive due anni, un ratto vive tre,
una pecora vive 12 anni,
le tartarughe vivono a lungo, 150 anni,
il moscerino della frutta, quello
che si usa nei laboratori
che si trova sulla frutta che mangiamo
quando è un po' marcia, vive 3 mesi.
C'è un programma biologico
e quindi genetico scritto da qualche parte
che determina l'aspettativa
di vita massima
e noi non abbiamo assolutamente idea
di dove stia questo programma
non sappiamo rispondere alla domanda
perchè un topo vive 2 anni
o un uomo vive 120
quando condividono più del 85%
dell'informazione genetica.
Il motivo è molto semplice, in realtà,
la nostra evoluzione,
la nostra permanenza sul pianeta
non è dettata dalla selezione
naturale sul nostro organismo
ma è dettata dalla selezione
naturale sui nostri geni
quindi noi siamo semplicemente
delle macchine biologiche
che devono trasmettere
la nostra informazione genetica
alla nostra progenie,
quindi quando la nostra progenie
è a sua volta autonoma
per trasmettere queste
informazioni ai propri figli
e noi come specie umana siamo
rimasti anche un po' più in vita
per vedere anche i nostri nipoti, ecco che
allora non serviamo più sul pianeta,
quindi è giusto che
l'evoluzione ci faccia fuori
perché non diventiamo dei competitori
dei nostri figli o dei nostri nipoti
per l'accesso alle risorse sul pianeta.
Non sappiamo dove stia l'inghippo,
però sappiamo sicuramente qualcosa
che mentre noi invecchiamo
si vanno a esaurire, forse è proprio
questa la causa dell'invecchiamento,
si vanno a esaurire quelle che sono
le capacità di riparazione e rigenerazione
della maggior parte
dei nostri organi e tessuti.
Voi immaginate che noi
abbiamo una barriera fissa,
un muro fisso invalicabile, e
progressivamente con la medicina,
con l'alimentazione,
con le condizioni igieniche
stiamo avvicinandosi a questo muro
e mentre ci avviciniamo a questo muro
esauriamo le risorse di riparazione
dei nostri organi e tessuti.
Per esempio prendete il cuore,
voi potete prendere
il cuore di un paziente,
di un individuo normale,
come di un topo, adulto
prendete le sue cellule del cuore
le mettete in laboratorio e troverete
queste magnifiche cellule che sono
una specie di mattoncini molto lunghi
alcuni hanno due nuclei,
che sono questi in blu,
in questa diapositiva, le striature sono
l'apparato che consente alla cellula
di contrarsi ritmicamente
70 volte al minuto
potete tenerle in laboratorio
e potete studiarle,
potete farci tutti quegli studi,
non riuscirete mai
secondo le tecnologie attuali,
almeno fino a un paio di anni fa,
a farle riprodurre.
Cioè noi nasciamo con un numero
di cellule nel nostro cuore
e queste sono le stesse cellule
con cui poi andremo a morire
quando la nostra vita si sarà esaurita.
Pensate è fantastico pensare che
delle cellule, che per miliardi di volte,
si contraggono ritmicamente
in una persona di 70 anni
ma sono esattamente le stesse
con cui questa persona era nata.
Col cervello andiamo ancora peggio,
perché le cellule del cervello
smettono di replicarsi
un po' prima della nascita addirittura.
Noi nasciamo con circa una cinquantina
di miliardi di cellule nel cervello
e, non soltanto, non si replicano più
ma ne perdiamo circa 80 mila ogni giorno.
Io sono qua che parlo
con voi, voi mi ascoltate
stiamo tutti perdendo cellule.
Possibilità di recupero di queste cellule:
assolutamente nessuna
Cioè quello che succede è che tutti noi
siamo figli di un ovocita,
l'ovocita di nostra madre e
lo spermatozoo di nostro padre.
La fecondazione di questo ovocita
da parte dello spermatozoo dà origine
alla prima cellula dell'organismo,
in biologia si chiama lo zigoto,
e poi questa cellula diventa due,
diventa quattro, diventa 8, diventa 16.
Dopo 4 o 5 giorni dalla fecondazione
è una sferetta di circa 150 cellule,
si chiama blastocisti,
e poi queste cellule
cominciano a specializzarsi.
Allora, l'organismo adulto
come voi, come me
contiene circa 100 mila miliardi
di cellule diverse,
ciascuno con una specializzazione:
una fa la cellula del cuore,
una fa il neurone,
una fa la cellula globulo bianco,
una fa la cellula della pelle,
una la cellula della retina.
Ci sono circa 240 tipi
di specializzazioni diverse.
Ma alcune di queste cellule
non si replicheranno mai più;
quelle della cute continuano
a replicarsi durante tutta la vita,
quelle dell'intestino, quelle del sangue
lo fanno, ma le cellule del cuore no,
le cellule del cervello no,
le cellule del pancreas no,
le cellule della maggior parte
degli organi non lo fanno.
E allora se voi avete
un po' questa visione,
vi stupite che ci sia questa enorme
diffusione delle malattie degenerative,
pensate soltanto al morbo di Alzheimer.
Il morbo di Alzheimer
è dovuto alla perdita di neuroni,
un particolare tipo
di neuroni nel cervello
colpisce una persona su tre
dopo gli 80 anni,
una persona su tre dopo gli 80 anni,
dopo che vi ho appena detto
che gli uomini vivono più di 80 anni
e che le donne più di 85 anni
una vera epidemia.
Un mio amico e collega
negli Sati Uniti inizia i suoi seminari
guardando le persone e chiedendo
a ciascuno di guardare
chi è seduto alla sua sinistra,
chi è seduto alla sua destra,
e di decidere chi di loro tre morirà
di una malattia cardiovascolare,
perché questa è la realtà:
30 percento delle persone muoiono
di una malattia cardiovascolare
che nella maggior parte dei casi è dovuta
all'incapacità del cuore di rigenerarsi
e quindi di andare incontro
a riparazione nella vita adulta;
invece che andare incontro a una malattia
che si chiama scompenso cardiaco,
15 milioni di nuove diagnosi
di scompenso cardiaco ogni anno nel mondo.
E dopo i 75 anni, una persona
su tre non ci vede bene
perché ha avuto
una degenerazione della retina
e la retina non si ripara.
Una persona su due, dopo i 75 anni,
non ci sente bene
perché ha avuto una degenerazione,
quindi una perdita delle
cellule dell'orecchio interno.
La sordità è qualcosa che noi
associamo spontaneamente alla vecchiaia
ma in realtà è una malattia
dovuta alla perdita di cellule
all'incapacità di queste
cellule di replicarsi.
Allora dobbiamo trovare pezzi di ricambio.
Pezzi di ricambio vuol dire
trovare sostanzialmente cellule.
Dove troviamo queste cellule per
riuscire a rigenerare questi organi
visto che spontaneamente non ce la fanno?
Bhe la cosa più ovvia
è prenderle da un embrione.
Noi possiamo tranquillamente,
come si fa nelle cliniche della fertilità,
prendere una cellula uovo,
prendere uno spermatozoo,
fare la fecondazione,
coltivare questo embrione
in un laboratorio in provetta
per quattro o cinque giorni,
finché forma questa sferetta
che sia chiama blastocisti
poi la sferetta viene disgregata,
le cellule che la formano
si chiamano cellule embrionali staminali,
possono coltivarli indefinitamente.
Possono ottenerne molti, molti miliardi
e poi convincere queste cellule
a diventare una cellula specializzata.
Per esempio, queste sono delle cellule
di un embrione di topo
che noi abbiamo fatto diventare
delle cellule di cuore,
vedete che anche in laboratorio
in provetta si contraggono simultaneamente
che è una caratteristica
delle cellule del cuore.
Noi prendiamo queste cellule
e le mettiamo all'interno del cuore
di un topolino infartuato,
rigeneriamo completamente il cuore.
Tutto bello, tutto bello, però di fatto
questo è molto problematico;
primo perché ci vuole un embrione,
secondo perché, secondo
molte accezioni culturali, religiose,
un embrione se fosse impiantato
darebbe origine a una nuova vita
quindi stiamo distruggendo delle vite,
e terzo poi perché un embrione è un essere
che dal punto di vista della medicina
è diverso dal punto di vista immunologico
quindi dovremmo trattare
questo tipo di trattamento
come se fosse un trapianto di reni,
un trapianto di cuore.
Quindi fare immunosoppressione
con tutta una serie di altri problemi,
quindi un problema è: possiamo ottenere
questi pezzi di ricambio
senza dover passare attraverso
la fertilizzazione di un uovo,
un uovo e uno spermatozoo.
La risposta è stata 'no' fino al 1997,
quando improvvisamente un gruppo
di veterinari scozzesi pubblica
su una delle principali
riviste internazionali
un esperimento che ha fatto scalpore
ed è finito su tutti i giornali,
che è la creazione della pecora Dolly.
Com'è stata fatta Dolly?
È stata fatta bypassando
il processo della fecondazione,
cioè prendendo un uovo
di una pecora donatrice
e prendendo una cellula adulta
di un individuo
da cui è stata estratta
l'informazione genetica,
è stato preso il nucleo
e trasferito nell'uovo,
in quel momento quel nucleo
di una cellula adulta
quindi una cellula specializzata
che non si replicava più,
per qualche motivo ha pensato di essere
il prodotto di una fecondazione
e ha dato origine a un nuovo embrione.
Quindi ha tagliato completamente fuori
il problema della fecondazione.
Però chi di nuovo ha
una visione religiosa della vita dice:
"Sì ma facendo questo tu,
in realtà, crei comunque un embrione,
crei comunque una blastocisti.
Se questa fosse impiantata in un utero
darebbe origine a una pecora Dolly,
quindi se io lo facessi in un uomo,
questo embrione potrebbe dare origine
a un essere umano."
Quindi non è che posso trovare qualcosa
che consenta di evitare completamente
il problema degli embrioni?
Di nuovo la risposta è stata
'no' per altri dieci anni,
finché nel 2006, questo signore,
che si chiama Shinya Yamanaka,
che ha vinto il premio Nobel
per la medicina nel 2012,
ha insegnato alla comunità scientifica
una maniera del tutto
rivoluzionaria per farlo, e ha detto:
"Io posso prendere
una cellula di qualsiasi individuo,
per esempio una cellula della pelle
o una cellula del sangue,
inserire all'interno di questa
cellula soltanto quattro geni,
e questi geni convincono questa cellula
a diventare una cellula dell'embrione."
Ecco che allora io posso coltivare
questa cellula dell'embrione
e ottenerne molti miliardi,
convincerle a diventare
una cellula di cuore, per esempio,
metterla nel cuore dopo l'infarto
e rigenerare il cuore.
Qui non ci sono embrioni, non c'è
possibilità di fare nuovi esseri umani.
Se la soluzione sembra perfetta,
è un po' imperfetta
dal punto di vista tecnico
perché è molto difficile ottenerlo.
Soltanto quest'anno, il mese scorso,
è ripartita una sperimentazione
in Giappone per cercare
di rigenerare l'occhio,
perché la tecnologia
talmente è ancora non robusta
che non consente di fare grandi
quantità di cellule per fare il cuore,
il fegato, o tanto meno il cervello,
ma consente probabilmente di fare
un piccolo quantitativo di cellule
che potrebbe essere
utile per rigenerare la retina.
Ci potrebbero essere
delle soluzioni diverse,
cerchiamo di essere un po' immaginativi.
Per esempio, andiamo a vedere come fanno
altri organismi
a rigenerare i propri organi.
Per esempio, se voi prendete
molti pesci, uno di questi pesci
è il pescetto Zebra di laboratorio,
Zebra fish, oppure le salamandre,
e poi potete tagliare grandi
porzioni del loro corpo:
la coda, le pinne, fare
un danno alla retina,
fare danno a un cuore e
questi rigenerano spontaneamente.
Questo è un animaletto molto interessante.
Si chiama Axolotl, che è un nome maya,
perché questo animale
vive sui vulcani spenti
a 4000 metri del Messico, del Nicaragua.
È un animale storico,
bloccato allo stato larvale,
voi potete prenderlo,
tagliare una sua zampa
e questa zampa nell'arco
di 40 giorni ricresce spontaneamente.
Ricresce spontaneamente
in maniera completa,
ricresce come anatomia, come ossa,
come nervi, come muscoli, come dimensioni.
Non potete tagliarla soltanto una volta
per farla ricrescere,
potete tagliarla 100 volte,
e 100 volte questa zampa ricrescerà.
Questi animali hanno dentro
un programma biologico
che consente a loro di fare
quello che noi mammiferi
sappiamo fare solo una volta nella vita
durante il nostro sviluppo embrionale.
Noi sappiamo fare un arto,
ma non sappiamo rifarlo
una volta che questo è stato tagliato.
Come fanno a rigenerare questi animali?
Non lo fanno con le cellule staminali
messe dall'esterno,
ma lo fanno perché hanno
dei geni che gli consentono di farlo.
Allora un po' di anni fa abbiamo detto:
"Andiamo a cercarli questi geni,
andiamo a cercare quali sono
i geni che potrebbero far rigenerare,
per esempio, il cuore
di un uomo, di un mammifero."
E abbiamo pensato che questi geni
devono essere dei geni non convenzionali,
allora il nostro patrimonio
genetico contiene
circa 20 mila pezzi di informazioni,
quelle che chiamiamo geni
per fare circa 20 mila proteine,
e questo è quello che
la genetica classica insegna.
Ma da una decina di anni noi sappiamo
che oltre a questi 20 mila geni classici,
ce ne sono almeno duemila
che contengono, non delle informazioni
per fare delle proteine,
ma per fare dei piccoli RNA regolatori.
Piccoli vuol dire che sono
veramente molto piccoli:
21, 22 mattoncini li formano
e si chiamano MicroRNA.
E allora ci siamo chiesti:
"Ma non sarà che all'interno di questi
duemila MicroRNA ce ne sono alcuni
che riescono a rimettere in moto la
proliferazione delle cellule del cuore?"
Quindi abbiamo fatto questa ricerca
con uno screening robotizzato
e alla fine ne abbiamo trovato qualcuno
che è in grado effettivamente
di far proliferare
le cellule del cuore in laboratorio.
Non soltanto è in grado di far proliferare
le cellule del cuore in laboratorio,
ma una volta messe nel cuore
le fa proliferare anche nel cuore.
Questa è stata una scoperta nuova
perché in qualche maniera ci dà
la possibilità di pensare
in maniera diversa.
Allora pensate a un paziente
con l'infarto del miocardio,
cosa succede a questo paziente,
che se è fortunato
di vivere nella nostra società,
viene portato rapidamente in ospedale,
e se arriva in un'unità coronarica
entro tre, quattro ore
dal momento dell'infarto,
il prima arriva meglio è,
ecco che il cardiologo
entra con un catetere
nella sua arteria coronaria,
apre un palloncino e ripristina
la pervietà dell'arteria coronaria,
cioè rimuove l'ostruzione.
Ma tutto quello che è morto
in queste due, tre, quattro ore
è qualcosa che
è destinato a non ricrescere,
a non riformarsi,
ma a essere sostituito da una cicatrice.
Immaginate ora di avere
questo stesso paziente
che quando viene diagnosticato l'infarto
gli viene iniettato dopo qualche giorno
dal momento in cui ha avuto riaperta
l'arteria coronaria,
uno di questi MicroRNA che
stimolano le sue cellule cardiache
a crescere, a fare un effetto salamandra,
cioè a moltiplicarsi,
ecco che la sua cicatrice
invece di formarsi sarà sostituita
da nuovo tessuto contrattile
che potrà in qualche maniera
accompagnarlo in una migliore vita.
Tutto molto bello farlo sui disegnini
però più difficile farlo in vivo,
però di fatto questa cosa funziona
nei piccoli animali.
Per esempio, se voi fate un infarto
a un topolino e gli iniettate
uno di questi MicroRNA invece che formarsi
delle grandissime cicatrici sul cuore,
si vengono a formare
delle piccolissime cicatrici
perché il resto del tessuto cardiaco
è stato rimpiazzato
dal nuovo tessuto contrattile.
Di nuovo, il cuore del topo
è qualcosa di così piccolo,
il cuore dell'uomo è molto più grande.
È difficile passare
dalla sperimentazione sul topo
alla sperimentazione sull'uomo,
ci vuole un modello di animale
che sia più vicino all'uomo.
Questo modello di animale
nelle malattie cardiovascolari
è sostanzialmente
rappresentato dal maiale.
Ecco allora che faccio
vedere dei risultati
che per noi sono molto molto eccitanti,
ottenuti con una tecnologia che permette
di vedere il cuore come funzione in vivo:
cioè dei filmini che vi danno un'idea
della contrazione cardiaca in vivo
ottenuti a Pisa dalla Scuola Sant'Anna
con la risonanza magnetica nucleare.
Quello sopra è un cuore infartuato.
Il cerchietto che con molta difficoltà,
vedete si contrae il ventricolo sinistro.
Ma il ventricolo sinistro un mese
dopo l'infarto è già molto dilatato,
vedete la parete è molto sottile,
è molto discinetico,
si muove abbastanza male,
e quindi questo sotto invece è un maiale
che è stato iniettato
subito dopo un infarto simile
con un MicroRNA che stimola
la rigenerazione cardiaca.
Voi intuitivamente,
senza essere cardiologi,
potete immediatamente vedere
che questo ventricolo rimane più piccolo,
non c'è dilatazione del cuore,
non c'è scompenso cardiaco,
la parete è più spessa
e la contrazione è più efficace.
Riusciremo a portare
questa cosa alla clinica?
Ovviamente è il nostro sogno
di ricercatori e di medici.
Ci sono ancora molti ostacoli anche
fra il maiale e la sperimentazione umana,
ma pian piano,
stiamo cercando di recuperarli.
Però la cosa che a me piace
di questo tipo di ricerca
è che segna una via nuova,
abbiamo passato dieci anni
a tormentarci con l'utilizzo
delle cellule staminali,
fra scandali nell'opinione pubblica
e insuccessi nella comunità scientifica.
Ecco che allora questo tipo di approccio,
è un approccio che a me piace chiamare
"rigenerazione dall'interno".
Non mettiamo più niente dall'esterno,
cerchiamo di utilizzare i geni,
e la funzione dei geni,
per rimettere in moto spontaneamente
la macchina del cuore,
nel nostro caso che si era inceppata, ma
sono sicuro che questo tipo di approccio
possa essere utilizzato
anche per rigenerare il pancreas,
rigenerare l'occhio,
rigenerare gli altri organi
e forse, se siamo fortunati,
anche a rigenerare i nervi e il cervello.
Con questo ho finito e vi ringrazio molto
per la vostra attenzione
(Applausi)